Last night's RNC speech from
Botox vampire Melania Trump was
monumentally important.
If Donald Trump is elected,
she'd be America's first lady,
and possibly
planet earth's final lady.
Unfortunately for her,
diligent Internet sleuths
discovered that she flat-out
ripped off
a Michelle Obama speech.
Take a look.
The values that you work hard
for what you want in life.
Like you work hard
-That your word is your bond.
And you do what you say.
That you do
what you say you're gonna do.
-That you treat people... -That
you treat people with respect.
-...with dignity and respect.
-They taught...
-Because we want our children
-and all children in this nation
to know -in this nation to know
-that the only limit
to the height
of your achievement
to your achievements
-is the reach of your dreams
-is the strength of your dreams
and your willingness
to work hard for them.
to work for them.
Yeah! It...
-(applause and cheering)
-Or no.
Actually, we didn't show
the whole thing.
Melania Trump's speech
does divert
at the end where she goes,
-"Blah, blah!" Uh...
-(laughter)
(like Sesame Street's Count):
One. One monotone trophy wife.
-Two. Two monotone trophy wives.
-(applause)
Three. Three monotone
trophy wives.
-(applause and cheering)
-(laughing) -(thunder sound)
Oh, well, really.
She's the third.
She's also inexplicably cribbed
a popular Internet meme.
Comedians, did she--
A: Rickroll everyone?
B: Tell a heart-wrenching tale
about two girls forced
to share one cup?
C: Refer to life
in small-town Slovenia
as "Oppa Gangnam Style"?
-Dave Holmes.
-She seems like a rickroller.
-I'm going with "A."
-Let's find out. Let's find out.
♪
MELANIA:
He will never, ever give up.
And most importantly,
he will never,
ever let you down.
-♪ Never gonna give you up
-LAPKUS: Oh, my God. -Yeah.
-♪ Never gone let you down...
-HOLMES: Here's the thing.
-Here's the thing.
-Yeah. And by the way...
we do have to thank...
we do have to thank Swog Blog,
who made this video
and put that all together.
-Dave, what were you gonna say?
-Yeah. But here's the thing,
history has proven that he
will run around and desert you.
(laughter)